bonjour et bienvenue dans ce programme
d'accompagnement l arrêt du tabac depuis
quelques temps vous songez sans doute à
vous débarrasser du tabac
or le fait que vous soyez avec moi dans
ce programme est déjà une première étape
dans votre parcours de sevrage tabagique
je vous propose un programme de sevrage
en douceur en douceur c'est à dire
adapté à votre rythme vous permettant de
continuer et de poursuivre la vie de
tous les jours sans cigarette votre
rythme c'est à dire qu'au fur et à
mesure des étapes
je vais vous accompagner pour être le
plus proche possible pour vous aider à
passer les caps difficiles ou moins
difficiles pour cela vous avez la
possibilité de prendre des traitements
les traitements les substituts
nicotiniques vous permettent un sevrage
en douceur en effet ce qui est
intéressant avec ses substituts
nicotiniques c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'interdît vous pouvez choisir d'arrêter
de fumer
d'un coup du jour au lendemain ou bien
si cela vous stresse moins d'arrêter
progressivement c'est à dire de faire
une diminution progressive en allant
vers l'arrêt complet de la cigarette
il n'y a en effet aucun danger à fumer
avec des substituts nicotiniques
contrairement aux idées reçues on sait
très bien que c'est dangereux de fumer
tout court mais pas plus avec un
traitement que son traitement
donc votre rythme sera important et je
vais vous accompagner pour que cela se
passe le plus facilement possible
ce programme contient aussi une partie
bien être qui vous sera présenté par
valérie barrès une spécialiste de
gymnastique et de sophrologie qui
accompagne aussi des personnes dans le
sevrage
j'accompagne mes patients depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans cela permet
de savoir que chaque personne est
différente et que chaque personne va
vivre son sevrage tabagique différemment
cela me permet aussi de vous dire que
vous devez vous méfier autour de vous
beaucoup de gens ou des expériences ces
expériences sont parfois très positif
dans le sevrage tabagique et ces gens là
vous pouvez très bien les écouter
d'autres personnes vont vous donner des
expériences plutôt négative de sevrage
tabagique et il faut surtout pas vous
laisser influencer par ces personnes là
vous devez donc parcourir votre sevrage
comme un après
il sage un apprentissage c'est à dire
que vous allez réapprendre à vivre la
vie de tous les jours sans tabac vous
allez donc réapprendre une vie un peu
plus saine une vie plus agréable
une vie sans dépendance et c'est ça mon
but c'est que vous puissiez arrêter de
fumer en douceur si vous ressentez le
besoin d'une aide plus approfondie vous
pouvez vous tourner vers votre médecin
traitant ou vers des tabacologues et un
suivi plus approfondie vous sera
proposée le nombre d'années de tabagisme
n'a pas de conséquence sur le parcours
d'arrêt du tabac
c'est à dire que l'arrêt du tabac est
une démarche personnelle peu importe
depuis combien de temps vous fumez et
les traitements en général facilite ce
sevrage pour que cela se passe en
douceur
si vous êtes inquiet à l'idée de vous
arrêter de fumer
c'est normal vous êtes inquiet en effet
car vous ne pouvez vous imaginer sans
cigarette et sans ce que vous ressentez
quand vous ne fumez pas depuis quelques
heures
c'est à dire le syndrome de manque or il
est possible actuellement d'arrêter de
fumer sans ressentir ce manque
c'est à dire qu'avec des traitements
d'aidé à l'arrêt du tabac que vous
trouvez pour certains par massy sans
ordonnance vous pouvez arrêter de fumer
en étant accompagné sans ressentir ce
manque
vous ressentirez en revanche très
rapidement en un ou deux jours un
mieux-être et votre entourage sera
peut-être l'apprécier
voici quelques exemples d'idées reçues
sur le sevrage tabagique et sur les
substituts nicotiniques qui pourraient
être des freins à votre arrêt du tabac
vous pouvez y revenir à tout moment dans
les menus interactifs
est il dangereux de fumer avec des
substituts nicotiniques
il n'est pas particulièrement dangereux
de fumer avec des substituts
nicotiniques
ce qui est dangereux c'est de fumée pas
spécialement avec ou sans substituts
nicotiniques les substituts nicotiniques
si ils ne permettent pas un arrêt
complet du tabac ça peut vouloir dire
qu'ils sont sous dosés il faut alors
augmenter la dose des substituts
nicotiniques pour ne plus avoir envie de
prendre de cigarettes
peut-on utiliser les substituts
nicotiniques chez la femme enceinte la
femme enceinte peut prendre des
substituts nicotiniques
il n'y a pas de contre indication chez
la femme enceinte ce qui n'est pas bon
chez la femme enceinte c'est de
poursuivre un tabagisme souvent la femme
enceinte arrive à diminuer dans un
premier temps son tabagisme mais
n'arrivent pas toujours à être à zéro
cigarette dans ce cas les substituts
nicotiniques sont une bonne indication
pour l'aider à arriver à zéro cigarette
et à ne plus du tout intoxiqué son bébé
ni elle même chez qui les substituts
nicotiniques sont ils contre indiqués
les substituts nicotiniques ne sont
contre indiqués chez pearson aucune
pathologie ne contraint dit que les
substituts nicotiniques
aucune personne qui fume n'a de contre
indication aux substituts nicotiniques
combien de temps peut-on utiliser les
substituts nicotiniques
on peut utiliser les substituts
nicotiniques aussi longtemps que cela
est nécessaire et si souvent un des
secrets en tabacologie que tout le monde
n'a pas c'est à dire qu'il vaut mieux
continuer le traitement si cela est
nécessaire aussi longtemps que vous en
avez besoin
si vous ressentez une envie de fumer
soudaine alors que vous n'avez plus de
substituts nicotiniques depuis quelques
temps vous pouvez reprendre des
substituts nicotiniques
si la diminution des doses des
substituts nicotiniques se fait trop
rapidement l'envi de fumée risque de
revenir d'une manière trop importante et
trop forte
il vaut mieux donc y aller très
progressivement et suffisamment
longtemps
peut-on reprendre des traitements par
substituts nicotiniques
après avoir arrêté pendant une certaine
période on peut en effet arrêter de
fumer prend des substituts nicotiniques
tranquillement les diminuer puis arrêter
les substituts nicotiniques et un moment
donné ressentir à cause de la vie de
tous les jours une envie de fumer très
importante qui commence à durer tant ces
cas là vous pouvez parfaitement
reprendre un traitement avec des
substituts nicotiniques et recommencer
le sevrage
avec cette aide arrêter de fumer
est ce une question de volonté
c'est une idée reçue qui est la vie très
dure ce n'est en effet pas du tout une
question de volonté
l'arrêt du tabac c'est souvent une
question de prise en charge
d'accompagnement du sevrage pour que
celui ci se passe en douceur
l'arrêt du tabac sera différente chez
chaque personne parce que justement
c'est pas une question de volonté
or chaque personne qui veut arrêter de
fumer n'a pas le même parcours et cela
montre que ce n'est pas une question de
volonté mais une question qui dépend
d'un accompagnement d'un environnement
et aussi de ce que nous avons tous dans
notre cerveau comme substance permettant
d'être plus ou moins stressé pourquoi
certaines personnes peuvent arrêter de
fumer
du jour au lendemain sans aide et
d'autres n'y arrive pas alors certaines
personnes ont la chance d'avoir un
cerveau qui va très très rapidement
remettre en place un mécanisme de
sécrétion de substance que l'on appelle
les substances bien-être ces substances
permettent de se sentir bien
alors qu'on n'a plus la nicotine à
laquelle on était habitué depuis
longtemps la nicotine provoque au fur et
à mesure qu'elle est prise et que l'on
en est dépendant une sécrétion de
certaines substances que le cerveau ne
leur secret plus sans cette aide par la
nicotine
certaines personnes quand elles arrêtent
de fumer brutalement vont très
rapidement récupéré ce mécanisme de
fonctionnement de leur cerveau et vont
permettre à leur cerveau de fonctionner
normalement très vite
or d'autres personnes vont mettre
beaucoup plus de temps à récupérer ce
fonctionnement
ce n'est pas de leur faute mais elles
auront à ce moment-là besoin d'un
accompagnement probablement avec des
traitements pour que cela se passe en
douceur et qu'elle arrive à zéro
cigarette à la fin
voici le moment de faire le point sur
vos habitudes avec le tabac et sur ce
que vous attendez de l'arrêt ce bilan
vous permettra de choisir votre
stratégie d'arrêt du tabac
sélectionnez maintenant la réponse qui
vous correspond la nicotine contenue
dans les cigarettes est assimilable à
une drogue dure mais elle n'est pas
dangereuse elle n'est ni dangereuse pour
le coeur ni pour les poumons ni
cancérigène en revanche c'est une drogue
très addictogène c'est-à-dire qui
provoque une forte dépendance sa
dépendance est assimilable à celle de
l'héroïne
c'est à dire que quand on manque de
nicotine on ressent des signes de manque
extrêmement violent la fumée de
cigarette permet à la nicotine d'arriver
en sept secondes sur les récepteurs à la
nicotine
les récepteurs à la nicotine que vous
avez dans le cerveau détermine le nombre
de cigarettes que vous aller fumer
quotidiennement
en effet on fume à peu près toujours le
même nombre de cigarettes
quand vous inhaler la fumée de cigarette
vous inhalez plus de 4000 substances
toxiques
ce sont ces substances qui sont
mauvaises pour la santé entre autres
le monoxyde de carbone les goudrons paix
benzopyrène le monoxyde de carbone est
une substance qui diminuera
l'oxygénation dans votre sens quand on
fume on se sent plus essoufflée au
moindre effort on arrive de moins en
moins bien à faire un effort physique
le monoxyde de carbone se fixe à
l'hémoglobine l'hémoglobine est notre
transporteurs d'oxygène en effet
l'affinité du monoxyde de carbone pour
l'hémoglobine est 200 fois supérieure à
celle de l'oxygène or le rôle de
l'hémoglobine est de transporter de
l'oxygène le monoxyde de carbone prend
donc la place de l'oxygène
le bénéfice à l'arrêt du tabac se fait
ressentir immédiatement le monoxyde de
carbone disparaît en effet en 24 à 48
heures donc vous retrouver une
oxygénation normal un deux jours après
l'arrêt du tabac cela est très
encourageant
c'est à vous de choisir si vous voulez
arrêter de fumer
d'un coup ou bien diminuer
progressivement votre tabagisme
les deux sont possibles il faut de
toutes les façons respecter votre rythme
si vous avez la crainte de ne plus fumer
du tout du jour au lendemain
vous pouvez choisir de faire une
diminution progressive diminuer
progressivement quand on fume veut dire
au fur et à mesure se débarrasser des
cigarettes
le but doit toujours rester l'arrêt
total
mais la diminution progressive doit se
faire avec le moins de stress possible
quand vous diminuez la consommation de
cigarettes
le risque et dîna les plus forts sur
chaque cigarette l'intoxication est au
final la même pour éviter d'inhaler plus
fort sur chaque cigarette fumée
vous pouvez associer des formes orales
de nicotine aux cigarettes à chaque
envie de cigarettes essayer de prendre
une pastille ou une gomme ou line à
l'heure à la nicotine
cela vous permettra de ne pas prendre de
cigarettes
vous pouvez donc diminuer le nombre de
cigarettes tout en gardant le but 0
cigarette
au final si les substituts nicotiniques
ne suffisent pas sous forme orale vous
pouvez associer un patch encore une fois
il n'est pas dangereux de fumer avec des
patchs à la nicotine mais le but reste
toujours d'éliminer complètement les
cigarettes au fur et à mesure vous ferez
un jour sans cigarette puis un deuxième
puis un troisième
le but de cette diminution progressive
et de respecter votre rib d'effectuer un
sevrage en douceur vous pouvez donc
décidé d'un programme que vous faites
évoluer toutes les semaines de la
diminution du nombre de cigarettes
si vous sentez que cela devient trop
difficile à un moment donné vous pouvez
augmenter la dose des substituts
nicotiniques ou encore une fois associé
un patch aux formes orales denis côté
vous aurez au final la dose suffisante
pour vous permettre d'être à zéro
cigarette quand vous serez à zéro
cigarette
vous pouvez suivre notre programme
journalier
d'accompagnement à l'arrêt du tabac les
traitements par substituts nicotiniques
vous délivre une certaine dose de
nicotine quotidienne vous permettant de
ne pas ressentir les effets désagréables
du manque la nicotine en effet n'est pas
dangereuse nous l'avons déjà dit mais
c'est important de le repréciser vous
pouvez donc prendre ces traitements
aussi longtemps que cela est nécessaire
c'est à dire plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années
si vous avez besoin de ces traitements
pour vous débarrasser de la cigarette
c'est important de le faire aussi
longtemps que possible
la nicotine n'étant pas dangereuse quand
vous arrêtez de fumer avec des
substituts nicotiniques vous arrêtez
l'intoxication due à la cigarette
ces substituts sont en vente libre en
pharmacie
vous pouvez donc vous les procurer sans
ordonnance médicale
ils permettent d'éviter d'être en manque
d' éviter de ressentir de l'anxiété
d'éviter dans la plupart des cas la
rechute dans le tabagisme d'éviter aussi
de prendre du poids
la meilleure manière de prendre ce
traitement est d'associer en général un
patch avec des formes orales de nicotine
l'association des deux en effet permet
de ne pas ressentir le manque sur toute
la journée
comment en pratique effectuer ce
traitement
vous avez différentes sortes de
substituts nicotiniques les patchs les
pattes vous permettent d'avoir une dose
sur toute la journée
délivrée en continu de nicotine on peut
l'assimiler au traitement à libération
prolongée de certains médicaments contre
la douleur
il permet d'atténuer la plupart du temps
sur toute la journée
l' envie de fumer malgré ça vous aurez
envie de fumer par moments en
particulier les cigarettes dites
importante
après le déjeuner lors d'un moment de
stress lors d'un moment de convivialité
vous pouvez alors associer les formes
orales de nicotine vous pouvez associer
au patch toutes formes orales de
nicotine vous pouvez poser le patch
partout vous pouvez le mettre sur le
bras c'est assez classique mais vous
pouvez aussi le mettre dans le dos vous
pouvez le mettre sur les gens
si cela ne vous convient pas sur les
bras il faut changer d'endroit tous les
jours pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
d'irritation locale vous pouvez garder
lepage aussi longtemps que cela est
nécessaire
je vous conseille de ne pas diminuer la
dose du patch avant un mois quand vous
aurez trouvé la bonne dose de pages qui
vous correspond vous pourrez donc la
prolonger pendant un mois
et au bout d'un mois essayer de diminuer
la dose si vous ne vous sentez pas prêt
vous prolonger deux mois sans aucun
problème quand vous vous sentez prêt à
faire une diminution de la dose vous
passez tout doucement à la dose
inférieure
vous pouvez revenir à tout moment sur
une dose supérieure si le manque se fait
ressentir de manière plus importante
si vous fumez dès le matin en vous
levant je vous conseille de garder le
patch la nuit au début du sevrage pour
vous permettre d'avoir une certaine dose
de nicotine le matin en vous levant
si vous fumez plus de 30 minutes après
vous être levé vous pouvez très bien
mettre le patch le matin et n'enlever le
soir et ne pas avoir le patch la nuit le
patch la nuit peut vous aider à passer
des caps au début du sevrage tabagique
mais il peut aussi vous donner des rêves
bizarres voire des cauchemars si vous
avez une perturbation du sommeil avec
les pages
il faut l'enlever évidemment vous
couchant je vous conseille donc
d'associer les formes orales de nicotine
au patch quelles sont ses formes orales
il existe différentes sortes forme orale
vous permettant de trouver celle qui est
la plus appropriée à votre besoin et à
vos habitudes
si vous aimez les chewing gum il existe
des gommes à la nicotine
les dosages varie en fonction des gommes
il y à des gommes à 2 mg des gommes à 4
mg certaines sont aromatisés à la menthe
ou aux fruits
je vous conseille de faire en fonction
de ce qui vous plaît le plus en
particulier prendre des gommes
aromatisés si vous n'aimez pas le goût
de la nicotine
si vous trouvez que ses gommes vous
piquent dans la gorge c'est probablement
que vous les avez trop fortement mâché
il faut alors les laisser contre la joue
pour que la nicotine se diffuse
tranquillement et arrive à votre cerveau
en deux trois minutes assez rapidement
vous ressentirez un effet d'apaisement
et vous n'aurez plus envie de fumer
vous pouvez en prendre aussi souvent que
vous le désirez les comprimés ou pastier
la nicotine il existe des comprimés est
dépassée à la nicotine aromatisés pour
certains pour vous permettre d'avoir un
goût agréable dans la bouche et de
calmer une envie de fumer
en quelques minutes vous pouvez en
prendre autant que vous voulez associés
ou non au patch lina leur lina leur est
un petit tube blanc qui contient une
cartouche contenant de la nicotine vous
pouvait aspirer des bouffées nicotine à
chaque envie de fumer ça permet de
retrouver un petit peu le geste de la
cigarette tout en n'étant pas toxiques
parce que vous n'y allez que de la
nicotine
certaines personnes aiment cette manière
de prendre de la nicotine qui ressemble
à la cigarette
si ces traitements par substituts
nicotiniques ne suffisent pas vous
pouvez toujours augmenter la dose vous
pouvez augmenter la dose d'efforts moral
de nicotine mais vous pouvez aussi
multiplié les patchs jusqu'à ce que vous
ressentiez que vous n'avez plus de
manque de nicotine
il existe aussi des traitements médicaux
dada l'arrêt du tabac
ces traitements sont sur prescription
médicale ils sont aussi efficaces dans
l'aide à l'arrêt du tabac
ils agissent en général sur les
récepteurs nicotiniques ou sur certaines
parties du cerveau votre médecin ou
votre tabacologue pourra vous
accompagner dans cette démarche en vous
prescrivant ces traitements
vous pouvez aussi compléter votre
sevrage tabagique avec les thérapies
cognitivo-comportementales elles vous
aideront à changer au fur et à mesure et
à évoluer dans votre vie sans cigarette
toutes ces méthodes sont
scientifiquement reconnues il existe
aussi d'autres méthodes qui peuvent vous
apporter un bénéfice comme par exemple
hypnose ou l'acupuncture qui peuvent
être des compléments intéressant dans
votre parcours d'arrêt du tabac
la bonne méthode est celle qui vous
conviendra le mieux pour arrêter en
douceur progressivement et vous libérer
du tabac
lors du sevrage tabagique vous pouvez
rencontrer des difficultés
mais ces difficultés nous pouvons toutes
les gérer je vais vous accompagner pour
trouver les solutions
si nécessaire on peut être allergique
aux patchs et ne pas les supporter du
tout certaines personnes ont du mal à
supporter les patchs du début à la fin
de la pause du patch il est alors
recommandé de prendre des anti
allergique qui s'appelle des
antihistaminiques qui peuvent être
prescrit par votre médecin pour calmer
cette allergie
il faut savoir qu'avant de prendre des
anti allergique vous pouvez aussi
changer d'endroit
parfois la peau est moins sensible à
d'autres endroits comme par exemple la
peau du dos ou bien sûr les jambes
vous pouvez donc mettre le patch où vous
le voulez échanger tous les jours
l'emplacement pour éviter justement ces
réactions allergiques
d'autres personnes ont une démangeaison
au début de la mise du patch les
quelques premières minutes cela n'a pas
d'importance
et ça passe en général assez rapidement
le manque le manque peut être assez
fréquent en début de ce virage il est
souvent bien gérée si vous prenez la
bonne dose de traitement
mais il peut aussi traduire un sous
dosage de traitement il peut être
atténuée quand c'est un manque subi
soudain il peut être atténuée par la
prise de substitution orale il va
souvent duré peu de temps mais de
manière assez fluctuante et il peut être
assez soudain si soudainement vous avez
envie de fumer vous pouvez prendre des
traitements comme des gommes ou des
pastilles pour atténuer ce manque
si le manque et continue et se poursuit
au fur et à mesure de la journée
cela peut traduire un sous dosage en
substituts nicotiniques
si les traitements malgré l'augmentation
des doses ne sont pas suffisamment
efficace il faudra peut-être changer de
traitement
le manque peut être aussi calmé par la
prise d'un verre d'eau ou par un
changement d'activité en effet souvent
ce changement d'activité permet de
penser à autre chose et d'atténuer ce
manque qui durent finalement que
quelques minutes
au fur et à mesure du temps vous verrez
que le manque se fera de moins en moins
fréquent et durera de moins en moins
longtemps dans la partie bien-être vous
trouverez aussi des exercices vous
permettant justement de gérer à la
maison ou au travail
ces moments de manque ils vous
permettront
vous détendre de bien respirer et
d'oublier ses manques
il peut arriver lors du sevrage
tabagique que vous ayez tendance au bout
de trois à quatre semaines d'arrêt du
tabac à vous sentir un petit peu déprimé
c'est une étape qui peut passer assez
rapidement si vous prenez un petit peu
plus de nicotine cela peut vous aider à
passer cette étape si vous avez tendance
à être dépressif en général il est
important de consulter un médecin pour
vous faire accompagner et aider pour que
cette étape ne soit pas trop difficile
et pour que vous puissiez la passer le
plus vite possible
la cigarette est un excitant en général
quand on arrête de fumer
le sommeil est bien meilleure il peut
arriver cependant que le traitement de
patch la nuit provoque des rêves
anormaux voir des cauchemars si le patch
vous gênent la nuit il suffit de
l'enlever et le sommeil redevient normal
il peut vous arriver aussi de rêver que
vous fumez la nuit ce n'est pas toxique
et c'est assez fréquent et ça disparaît
assez rapidement ça ne doit pas vous
inquiéter
vous allez être peut-être un petit peu
plus irritables au début du sevrage
il faut que votre entourage soit
tolérant et accepte que pendant quelques
temps vous soyez un petit peu plus
irritables que d'habitude
il faut savoir que vous fait
l'apprentissage de la vie sans tabac
vous ne mettez plus un écran de fumée
entre votre entourage
et vous où entre vos problèmes et vous
donc au fur et à mesure vous allez
réapprendre la vie et l'irritabilité va
s'atténuer
vous pouvez aussi pour vous défouler ou
vous détendre vous reporter à la partie
bien-être de ce programme les pièges à
éviter lors de votre parcours vous
pouvez rencontrer des pièges
si vous en avez connaissance vous pouvez
plus facilement les éviter la prise
d'alcool
l'alcool est le plus grand stimulant des
envies de fumer
en général quand on prend un verre
d'alcool on prend une cigarette par la
suite il faut donc éviter ce piège il
faut savoir que si vous prenez de
l'alcool l' envie de fumer peut être
très importante elle peut être géré avec
des formes orales de nicotine mais si
vous trouvez que c'est trop difficile de
ne pas prendre de cigarettes
quand on prend d'alcool je vous
conseille de ne pas prendre d'alcool
pendant les deux ou trois premières
semaines d'arrêt du temps
cela peut vous aider à éviter ce piège
qui peut finalement être résolus assez
rapidement si cela vous semble très
difficile de ne pas prendre d'alcool du
tout tous les jours il est peut-être
nécessaire de vous faire accompagner par
un médecin la prise de café le café
appelle souvent l'envi de cigarettes
si vous trouvez que cela est trop
difficile au début il est peut-être
nécessaire de remplacer le café par du
thé par exemple du chocolat le matin le
café peut ne pas être un problème
parfois simplement les traitements à
base de nicotine vont vous aider à
prendre du café sans avoir besoin de
prendre une cigarette par ailleurs le
cannabis peut être un piège
supplémentaires lors de l'arrêt du tabac
en effet si vous consommez du cannabis
il faut savoir que c'est une substance
aussi dangereux si ce n'est plus que le
tabac elle contient les mêmes substances
toxiques agissant sur le corps donc les
substances cancérigènes les substances
qui aggrave la santé mais est-ce
contient en plus des substances qui
agissent directement sur le cerveau et
diminue la possibilité de concentration
quand on s'arrête de fumée si on
n'arrête pas la consommation de cannabis
on continue à consommer en consommant du
cannabis de la nicotine
la consommation de cannabis peut
augmenter les risques de rechute dans le
tabac si vous prenez de temps en temps
d'une manière festive le cannabis
lorsque vous prenez le cannabis cela
peut augmenter l'envi de fumée d'une
manière très importante
il est donc évidemment conseillé
d'arrêter le cannabis aussi si vous
consommez quotidiennement du cannabis je
vous conseille évidemment d'arrêter les
deux pour un sevrage tabagique réussi
mais vous aurez probablement besoin
d'une aide supplémentaire
cette aide peut être fait par une
augmentation des doses de nicotine qui
sera en général nécessaire mais aussi
parfois de traitement contre l'anxiété
en effet une consommation quotidienne de
cannabis peut être une manière de gérer
un stress ou bien des troubles du
sommeil
dans les deux cas vous aurez
probablement besoin d'une aide
médicamenteuse pour vous aider à gérer
ces moments difficiles
dans ces cas là je vous conseille
évidemment de consulter
spécialiste ou un médecin pour vous
apporter l'aide nécessaire lors des
soirées vous pouvez être sollicités à
fumer en effet plusieurs personnes
peuvent fumer autour de vous ou vous
proposer des cigarettes
sachez évidemment les refuser sachez
aussi exprimé que vous êtes en sevrage
tabagique
certaines personnes qui ont déjà arrêté
de fumer pourront vous encourager
d'autres seront probablement très
intéressé par votre parcours vous pouvez
aussi mettre un demi pas de champ plus
une heure avant d'aller dans une soirée
pour vous aider à passer ce cas les
formes orales de nicotine peuvent aussi
vous aider
lord envie soudaine de fumer pendant ces
soirées attention gens fument juste une
peut être un piège en effet au bout d'un
certain temps vous vous sentirez plus à
l'aise dans votre parcours d'arrêt du
tabac
vous penserez donc qu'une cigarette ne
peut vous faire de mal
al'inverse en fait une cigarette peut ré
ouvrir vos récepteurs à la nicotine qui
se trouve dans votre cerveau et
rapidement vous rendre de nouveau
dépendant de la cigarette c'est comme ça
que beaucoup de gens reprennent même au
bout d'un certain temps
au bout d'un certain nombre de mois au
bout d'un certain nombre d'années
ces personnes pensent être à l'abri est
en fait en prenant une cigarette
elles recommencent à fumer deux ou trois
ou six cigarettes
et puis le paquet revient très
rapidement si vous êtes en train de
reprendre de temps en temps une
cigarette ça chez rapidement l'éliminer
avant que l' envie de fumer ne devienne
trop forte
si vous sentez que vous avez de plus en
plus envie de fumer vous pouvez très
bien reprendre un traitement en
particulier les substituts nicotiniques
pour une certaine période
si cela est nécessaire même si vous les
avez arrêté depuis un certain temps
l'entourage et oui l'entourage c'est
important il peut être un obstacle ou
bien un atout à votre réussite
sachez prévenir les gens autour de vous
sachez demandé aux gens qui habitent
avec vous s'il fut de ne pas fumer dans
la même pièce que vous ou bien de fumer
à l'extérieur de l'endroit où vous
habitez
ils pourront alors vous encourager lors
de votre parcours et vous aider à
continuer le sevrage et à le réussir
faut-il garder ou ne pas garder les
cigarettes quand on arrête de fumer
il est important de se poser la question
si le fait de voir des objets liés au
tabac vous donne envie de fumer ou pas
du tout si c'est le cas en effet il faut
les éliminer au maximum les éloigner ou
les cacher pour ne pas les voir tous les
jours quotidiennement les cigarettes
vous pouvez au départ les garder pas
trop proche pour ne pas avoir la
tentation immédiate mais un endroit où
vous savez qu'elles sont là pour vous
rassurer
si cela vous semble important si au
contraire vous pensez que c'est une
stimulation supplémentaire de risque
dans vie de fumée vous pouvez les
éloigner voir vous en débarrasser
complètement si vous gardez quelques
cigarettes je vous conseille de ne pas
les garder proche de vous ne pas les
garder sur vous mais de les mettre à un
endroit vous pouvez à tout moment
aller les chercher mais vous allez faire
une démarche qui vous permettra de
réfléchir et peut-être d'éviter
finalement d'allumer la cigarette les
briques et les cendriers il faut dans la
mesure du possible les faire disparaître
de votre vue si vous voyez en effet un
briquet très souvent vous avez
automatiquement la pensée cigarettes
bravo pour cette décision vous avez en
effet décidé de débuter votre sevrage
tabagique
vous pouvez vous en féliciter et vous
pouvez solliciter l'encouragement de
votre entourage vous allez dans une
première étape décider du jour de début
d'arrêt du tabac
même si votre parcours d'arrêt du tabac
débute par une diminution dans un
premier temps cette première étape
constitue le début de votre engagement
dans l'apprentissage de la vie sans
cigarette le jour d'arrêt du tabac ou de
diminution du tabac ce premier jour peut
être un jour férié comme un jour
travailler prenez ce qui vous semble le
plus facile si cela vous convient mieux
lors de votre travail vous le ferez à ce
moment là si cela vous convient mieux
quand vous ne travaillez pas choisissez
un jour férié
prévoyez un emploi du temps qui vous
occupera sans pour autant vous stresser
inutilement n'oubliez pas aussi de
prendre le traitement que vous avez
prévu
si vous avez prévu de prendre par
exemple des substituts nicotiniques
prévoyez aussi de pouvoir changer
d'activité si vous avez un moment une
envie de fumer
voici ce qui va se passer au fur à
mesure du début de l'arrêt du tabac vous
allez très rapidement vous débarrasser
du monoxyde de carbone et retrouver une
oxygénation normal vous allez donc vous
sentir mieux
vous allez mieux pouvoir respirer au
moindre effort ce bénéfice est très
important car il intervient
immédiatement après le début de l'arrêt
du tabac même si vous avez décidé de
diminuer dans un premier temps vous
allez ressentir un bien-être par cette
diminution de la prise des cigarettes
bonjour ça fait maintenant 24 heures que
vous n'avez pas fumer bravo vous
ressentez probablement déjà le bien-être
de l'arrêt du tabac vous avez
probablement de temps en temps des
envies de fumer ses envies de fumer ne
dure pas très longtemps
vous pouvez les gérer en prenant des
gommes ou des pastilles et la nicotine
si vous avez très envie de fumer
vous pouvez aussi changer d'habitudes à
certains moments clés quand vous aviez
l'habitude de prendre des cigarettes
vous pouvez par exemple vous brosser les
dents en fin de repas pour éviter
d'avoir envie de fumer sachez que cette
première journée doit vous sembler
simple elle ne doit pas être trop
difficile
si vous trouvez que cette journée trop
difficile c'est que vous avez
probablement pas l'aide suffisante
il vous est important à ce moment là de
prendre des traitements par exemple des
substituts nicotiniques ou d'associer
d'autres formes de substituts
nicotiniques comme par exemple les
formes orales de nicotine vous pouvez
donc augmenter la dose de nicotine en
prenant des gommes ou des pastilles ou
bien tout simplement augmenter les
patchs si vous sentez que cette étape
est trop difficile
bonjour nous sommes arrivés à votre cas
jours sans tabac bravo vous ne vous
étiez probablement pas imaginer avant
que vous pouviez tenir quatre jours sans
fumée vous l'avez fait et ceci est une
étape irréversible c'est à dire que vous
avez réussi à passer plusieurs jours
sans tabac vous savez donc maintenant
que c'est faisable
vous pouvez donc poursuivre dans cette
voie et continuer les quatre jours
suivants sans tabac si vous rencontrez
des difficultés vous avez toujours la
possibilité de prendre conseil auprès de
votre pharmacien ou bien de votre
médecin ou bien d'augmenter tout
simplement les doses des traitements par
nicotine
si vous êtes actuellement avec des
substituts nicotiniques
vous pouvez aussi prendre contact avec
une personne de votre entourage qui peut
vous encourager dans votre sevrage si
vous êtes sous traitement par substituts
nicotiniques et que cela vous semble
assez simple surtout n'arrêtait pas le
traitement
c'est parce que vous êtes bien soutenu
par le traitement est bien équilibrée
que vous pouvez poursuivre votre sevrage
tabagique
il doit se passer en douceur comme c'est
le cas actuellement
ce dosage sera donc poursuivie au moins
un mois de traitement
ensuite l'un diminution pourra peut-être
se faire progressivement mais pas avant
un mois vous pouvez aussi planifier vos
moments de loisirs il est important de
favoriser l'activité physique
vous savez bien que pour gérer votre
poids c'est très important d'augmenter
votre activité physique
alors il faut réfléchir à ce que vous
aimez faire vous aimez peut-être marché
vous aimez peut-être planifier des
marches en famille ou bien seuls vous
aimez plus tôt peut-être courir ou bien
faire du vélo où elle est la piscine
peut-être que la danse vous convient
mieux
peut-être que vous aimez restez chez
vous vous n'aimez pas sortir et dans ces
cas-là le vélo d'appartement est une
très bonne solution
planifiez donc une activité physique qui
vous fasse plaisir
il faut toujours se faire plaisir quand
on arrête de fumer
cela fait maintenant une semaine que
vous avez arrêté de fumer bravo belle
victoire chacun développe ses astuces
pour l'arrêt du tabac
vous avez probablement mise en place des
astuces qui vous permettent de gérer
chaque envie de fumer
il est possible alors de prendre un
verre d'eau quand on a envie de fumer ou
bien de changer l'endroit de changer de
pièce de prendre des pastilles ou des
chewing-gums sans sucre évidemment à
chaque envie de fumer ou bien tout
simplement de prendre des gommes ou des
pastilles et la nicotine vous pouvez
aussi vous brosser les dents à chaque
fois après le repas pour éviter d'avoir
envie de la cigarette
après le repas vous avez donc mis en
place des mécanismes qui vous permettent
de gérer
bravo vous pouvez aussi si vous en avez
envie vous reporter à la partie bien
être de ce programme
pour vous aider avec des exercices de
relaxation ou bien de musculation si
vous rencontré de grandes difficultés
il est important de vous faire aider par
un professionnel de santé
il peut s'agir du traitement qui est mal
adaptée ou bien tout simplement d'un
moment difficile que le professionnel de
santé vous aidera à passer vous avez
aussi remarquer que vous êtes très
heureux d'avoir réussi à arrêter de
fumer depuis une semaine mais parfois
vous avez des doutes sur votre capacité
de poursuivre l'arrêt du tabac ces
doutes seront de moins en moins fréquent
et seront de moins en moins difficile à
surmonter
en effet le sevrage tabagique n'est pas
un long fleuve tranquille mais plus vous
avancez dans le temps plus la victoire
est au bout assez rapidement
bonjour sa fait déjà dix jours que vous
avez arrêté de fumer dix jours du point
de vue économique c'est déjà une belle
somme vous pouvez la x 3 et vous verrez
ce que vous économisez par mois vous
pouvez déjà faire des projets sur ce que
vous allez faire avec cet argent il est
très important de se motiver en
imaginant tout ce que l'on peut se faire
comme plaisir avec cette économie
d'argent
je vais aussi vous parler de la toux en
effet quand on fume on peut avoir ce que
l'on appelle la toux du fumeur l'atout
du fumeur c'est une toux qui a lieu
essentiellement le matin quand vous
arrêtez de fumer c'est tout disparaît
assez rapidement en effet en dix à
quinze jours
elle doit disparaître elle peut aussi
augmenter au début quand on arrête de
fumer parce qu'il ya une augmentation de
la sécrétion au niveau des bronches et
il ya une réactivation des petits seal
qui aident à éliminer les poussières
dans le poumon
tout ce système qui se met en place aide
à nettoyer le poumon c'est donc pour la
bonne chose que la tout augmente
au début du sevrage puis ensuite elle
doit disparaître complètement
si elle ne disparaît pas totalement au
bout de 15 jours il est important de
consulter un médecin pour voir pourquoi
cette toux ne disparaît pas si vous
rencontrez des difficultés lors de votre
parcours de sevrage tabagique
cela peut arriver mais c'est
parfaitement surmontable
souvenez-vous déjà que vous avez arrêté
de fumer depuis un certain temps c'est
déjà une grande victoire
souvenez vous aussi que chaque moment
est un moment supplémentaire vers la
victoire de la liberté sans tabac vous
pouvez aussi relire vos listes les
listes que vous avez effectué en début
de ce virage qui vous permettent de re
voir quelles sont vos motivations à
l'arrêt du tabac
vous pouvez aussi faire de nouvelles
listes mettant tous les points positifs
que vous ressentez depuis que vous avez
arrêté de fumer
vous pouvez vous souvenir que vous avez
retrouvé très probablement un meilleur
odorat un meilleur goût et peut-être une
meilleure endurance
n'oubliez pas que si vous avez de
réelles difficultés si vous avez très
envie de fumer avant de craquer il vaut
mieux augmenter les doses de nicotine
si vous êtes sous le plus fort patch
vous pouvez
ajouter un deuxième page vous pouvez
toujours aussi augmenter la consommation
des formes orales de nicotine pour
calmer les envies soudaines de fumée si
vos difficultés persistent il est
important de consulter un professionnel
de santé
déjà deux semaines sans tabac vous devez
déjà beaucoup apprécié la vie sans la
cigarette c'est bien de semaine c'est
déjà un beau parcours pour augmenter
votre motivation vous pouvez faire de
petits tests comme par exemple monter
deux ou trois étages à pied et remarqué
que vous êtes beaucoup moins essoufflé
ce test vous encourageront à poursuivre
votre arrêt du tabac
si par hasard vous rencontré quelques
difficultés vous pouvez toujours vous
reporter au chapitre sur la gestion des
effets indésirables lors du sevrage
tabagique ou bien des pièges à éviter et
cela vous permettra de passer ces
difficultés sans peine deux semaines
c'est bien mais faites attention à ne
pas tomber dans les pièges
faites attention ne pas prendre de
cigarette même une bouffée pourrait vous
donner très envie de refus mais votre
parcours est parfait
continuez donc à éviter les situations
dangereuses
bravo 3 semaines déjà je vous félicite
c'est un beau parcours
vous avez déjà 21 jours sans tabac vous
faites régulièrement je suppose la liste
des motivations qui continue à vous
aider dans votre parcours vous pouvez
aussi planifier vos week-ends pour
utiliser le temps que vous perdiez fumer
avant et pour pouvoir faire des
activités qu'il vous plaise n'oubliez
pas les activités physiques
c'est important pour la gestion de votre
poids il est aussi important de gérer
dans la journée les moments quotidiens
de plaisir qui vous aide à passer ces
moments qu'ils étaient des moments que
vous passiez à fumer
si vous ressentez une baisse de moral ça
peut arriver au bout de trois semaines
un mois d'arrêt du tabac
surtout n'hésitez pas à consulter à ce
moment là un professionnel de santé
cette baisse de moral peut arriver et
peut durer quelques jours puis
disparaître assez rapidement en
particulier
vous pouvez avoir besoin à ce moment là
d'augmenter un petit peu les doses de
nicotine
si vous êtes sous traitement par
substitution nicotinique cela est normal
et ça aide à calmer ses moments de
déprime ou d'anxiété
si ces moments ne passe pas il faut
rapidement consulté pour vous faire
aider par un médecin après trois
semaines de sevrage tabagique vous
ressentez probablement un calme une
certaine sérénité que vous appréciez qui
vous font découvrir la vie sans tabac
cela vous aide évidemment à poursuivre
votre parcours vous pouvez faire la
liste de tous les exemples personnels
qui vous sont chers par exemple une
odeur que vous retrouvez que vous
appréciez par exemple le goût des
aliments que vous allez retrouver la
possibilité de mieux vous bouger quand
vous faites du sport une possibilité de
mieux respirer quand vous faites un
parcours importants ou un effort
physique
tous ces moments positifs sont des
moments très importants a listé dans
votre parcours
bravo ça fait un mois vous avez arrêté
de fumer un mois c'est en même temps
court mais c'est déjà bien
c'est déjà très long c'est suffisant
pour que vous puissiez déjà savoir
comment éviter les pièges de l'arrêt du
tabac vous avez bien géré les choses
vous savez les éviter pour augmenter
votre motivation et poursuivre ce
sevrage
vous pouvez aussi faire la liste et
poursuivre cette liste de tous les
avantages que vous avez à l'arrêt du
tabac
les avantages physiques vous sentez
mieux vous respirez mieux le goût
l'odorat votre sommeil probablement est
meilleur vous pouvez aussi augmenter
votre motivation en calculant tout ce
que vous avez économisé jusqu'ici alors
vous me direz que vous avez payé des
traitements mais ces traitements de
toutes les façons reviennent moins cher
que le tabac calculer et vous verrez
n'oubliez pas de vous faire plaisir
quand on arrête de fumer il faut se
faire plaisir surtout si vous avez des
activités régulières poursuivait ses
activités régulièrement ça vous aidera
dans l'arrêt du tabac si vous avez un
traitement médicamenteux
cela ne fait donc un mois que vous le
prenez poursuivent et ce traitement ne
l'arrêté pas brutalement si vous vous
sentez confortable dans votre sevrage
tabagique que les envies sont gérables
que vous arrivez bien maîtriser les
choses
vous pouvez débuter au bout d'un mois
une diminution progressive des
traitements si vous sentez que certains
moments sont encore difficiles surtout
ce n'est pas le moment de diminuer la
dose
encore une fois ce ne sont pas les
traitements qui sont dangereux mais la
cigarette tout ce qui peut vous éviter
de reprendre le tabac il faut le
poursuivre vous pouvez donc
tranquillement continuer encore un mois
avec cette dose si vous êtes prêts et
vous sentez vous pouvez diminuer le
traitement comment procédez vous pouvez
diminuer la dose que vous avez
actuellement d'environ un quart ou un
tiers de la dose actuelle c'est à dire
si vous êtes avec un patch le plus fort
vous pouvez passer au dosage juste
inférieure diminué donc d'à peu près un
tiers votre dose d'apport nicotiniques
journalier si vous êtes à deux patchs
vous pouvez diminuer un des deux matches
passés à une dose un peu plus faible
avec un des deux patchs vous gardez un
gros patch est un patch moyens vous avez
donc une diminution en douceur de votre
dose de nicotine
cette diminution si elle s'effectue en
douceur vous permet de ne ressentir
aucun signe de manque c'est le but
si vous prenez des formes orales de
nicotine avec ou sans patch
ce n'est pas encore le moment de
diminuer la dose vous pouvez
tranquillement poursuivre la même dose
ou bien par moments si vous avez
simplement une petite envie de fumer
mais qui n'est pas très très forte
commencé à introduire des pastilles ou
des chewing-gums sans nicotine qui vous
permettront de diminuer ses envies assez
rapidement sans prendre de nicotine vous
pouvez aussi tout simplement prendre un
verre d'eau un mois ça fait déjà un mois
que vous avez arrêté de fumer
c'est vraiment bien moi bravo il faut
poursuivre si tout se passe bien on se
retrouve tranquillement dans deux
semaines sinon vous pouvez toujours
venir me voir et reprendre une partie de
ce programme
bonjour ça fait un mois et demi que vous
n'avez plus fumer bravo un mois et demi
c'est déjà beaucoup
un mois et demi que vous n'êtes plus
esclave de la cigarette que vous
retrouvez très probablement une
meilleure santé un meilleur bien-être
vous sentez mieux au niveau de la
respiration au niveau du sommeil et
physiquement
vous vous sentez mieux si vous
rencontrez des difficultés
ne vous en faites pas je peux vous
accompagne et vous aider il vous suffit
pour cela d'aller dans la partie
difficultés et pièges de ce programme et
nous allons voir ensemble comment
résoudre ce problème
on trouve toujours des solutions tous
les efforts que vous avez fournis jusque
là sont derrière vous
l'arrêt du tabac va s'avérer de plus en
plus facile c'est très encourageant
poursuivez votre sevrage tabagique
tranquillement au jour le jour sans vous
poser de questions sur l'avenir
en effet tout ce que vous avez passé
comme difficulté vous ne devriez pu les
rencontrer
il faut vous dire qu'au fur et à mesure
que l'on avance dans le sevrage
tabagique
cela devient de plus en plus facile mais
attention ne tombez pas dans le piège
d'une cigarette de temps en temps par ci
par là parce qu'on maîtrise les choses
c'est comme ça que l'on recommence à
fumer si vous reprenez une cigarette
le risque c'est de ré ouvrir vos
récepteurs à la nicotine
si vous ré ouvrir aux récepteurs et
nicotine vous aurez très envie de fumer
le lendemain puis le surlendemain vous
re prenait à ce moment là et vous
risquez de reprendre une cigarette après
l'autre c'est comme ça qu'on reprend le
tabagisme
alors attention les cigarettes de toutes
les façons après un mois et demi d'arrêt
ne sont plus bonnes mais tant mieux
en général elles ne sont plus agréables
à fumer et dans ces cas là aucun intérêt
de reprendre une cigarette
il vaut mieux continuer avec des
substituts nicotiniques
si vous sentez que l' envie de
cigarettes est très forte et dans ce cas
là vous pouvez reprendre à chaque moment
une pastille ou une gomen côtier vous
pouvez aussi si l'envi se fait de plus
en plus forte
réaugmenter les doses de traitement si
vous en ressentez le besoin sinon vous
continuer tranquillement à poursuivre
votre traitement en douceur et à
continuer ce sevrage tabagique
en ôtant toujours les points positifs de
l'arrêt du tabac qui vous permettent de
continuer votre parcours on se retrouve
dans deux semaines et on verra ensemble
ce qu'il en est
bravo ça fait deux mois que vous ne
fumez plus de moi c'est bien
peut-être qu'avant d'avoir fait cette
démarche vous n'auriez jamais pensé
pouvoir tenir deux mois et bien c'est
fait et c'est une grande victoire
deux mois c'est déjà beaucoup mais il
faut continuer il faut être vigilant
vous avez peut-être encore des
traitements
c'est tout à fait normal il faut
poursuivre les traitements
vous allez les poursuivre aussi
longtemps que cela est nécessaire
on n'est pas pressé les traitements ne
sont pas dangereux et vous empêche de
reprendre la cigarette qui elle est
dangereuse alors poursuivant les
traitements vous allez pouvoir au bout
de deux mois commencé à faire une
diminution progressive progressive ça
veut dire à votre rythme si vous passez
d'un dosage au dosage inférieur
il ne doit pas y avoir de changement
dans votre vie vous ne devez pas trouvé
ça très difficile
si vous trouvez ça très difficile vous
êtes allez un petit peu vite
vous allez donc revenir à une dose
supérieure si ça se passe bien vous
pouvez poursuivre à une dose inférieure
pendant en tout cas au moins un mois
voire plus deux mois de sevrage
tabagique
c'est déjà une grande période mais il
peut y avoir des moments vous sentez un
peu plus fragiles il ne faut pas hésiter
à ce moment là à prendre des substituts
nicotiniques les formes orales
si ça peut vous aider vous connaissez
déjà bien l'utilisation pour renforcer
le côté positif de cet arrêt du tabac
depuis deux mois
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez continuer à
faire des activités plaisantes des
activités agréables que vous faites sans
tabac toutes ces activités
si vous les faites de manière régulière
vous êtes d'une part à gérer la prise de
poids et d'autre part à apprécier le
fait que vous êtes non fumeurs il peut
s'agir de toutes sortes d'activités en
tout cas toujours des activités qui vous
font plaisir si tout se passe bien nous
nous retrouvons tranquillement dans un
mois en attendant si vous avez la
moindre difficulté n'hésitez pas je
serai là jour et nuit pour vous aider
vous pouvez toujours en effet revenir
vers ce programme est consulté les
partis qui vous intéresse si vous
rencontrez des difficultés
alors à bientôt
ça fait trois mois que vous avez arrêté
de fumer
trois mois c'est une bonne période vous
rendez compte que trois mois c'est un
quart d'année depuis un quart d'année
vous ne fumez plus bravo on va continuer
comme ça parce que vous êtes enfin
libéré de votre habitude de fumer tous
les jours depuis trois mois vous n'avez
plus besoin de la cigarette alors vous
pouvez continuer chez moi un an et
plusieurs années pour cela je vous
conseille de faire un petit peu
attention et d'être vigilants à chaque
avancée dans votre vie sans tabac faire
un petit peu attention au poids
régulièrement c'est-à-dire bouger il
faut surtout favoriser les activités
physiques pour maintenir un poids
constant non seulement pour le maintenir
constant mais aussi pour continuer à
vous sentir bien dans votre corps plus
vous bougez plus votre endurance
s'améliore et plus vous ressentez que
vous retrouvez une activité physique que
vous n'aviez probablement plus depuis
longtemps le poids peut être aussi gérer
si vous prenez un peu de poids par cette
augmentation d'activité physique
n'hésitez pas c'est toujours bon de
faire du sport vous êtes non fumeurs
votre reflex par rapport à la cigarette
et depuis un certain temps effacé mais
vous avez toujours des récepteurs de
nicotine dans votre cerveau n'oubliez
pas ces récepteurs qui actuellement
dorment et vous laisse tranquille et ne
vous embête plus ils peuvent se
réveiller à n'importe quel moment
il faut donc continuer à être vigilant
tout au long du sevrage tabagique et
poursuivre pendant les mois et les
années qui continue mais au fur et à
mesure vous allez oublié parce que votre
état normal sera d'être non fumeurs j
insiste fortement sur ce point parce que
reprendre une cigarette ou quelques
bouffées peut-être la cause de l'échec
au sevrage tabagique
beaucoup de gens en effet reprennent
leur tabagisme
après une simple cigarette une simple
envie de fumer quelques bouffées lors de
la prochaine étape nous allons nous
retrouver pour la diminution puis la fin
du traitement
n'hésitez pas c'est vous qui déciderez
quand c'est le moment d'arrêter le
traitement
ça peut être tout de suite comme ça peut
être dans un mois dans deux mois ou dans
six mois quand vous sentirez que les
doses
son minimum et que vous sentez que vous
êtes capable d'arrêter complètement le
traitement on peut se voir et je vous
expliquerai comment procéder si en
attendant vous en avez besoin vous
pouvez toujours revenir vers ce
programme et je serai toujours à votre
disposition pour vous aider si vous
rencontrez des difficultés n'hésitez pas
comment allez vous gérer maintenant au
fur et à mesure des semaines et des mois
qui viennent
votre traitement vous avez probablement
la dose suffisante actuellement de
traitement pour vous aider à ne pas
ressentir le manque
vous pouvez même par moment oublier ce
traitement il vous arrivera sans doute
certains matins d'oublier de mettre
votre page par exemple aucune importance
c'est déjà très positif ça veut dire que
vous ne pensez plus la cigarette le
matin mais par contre cela peut vous
faire un petit peu peur alors pour
éviter cela il faut prendre avec vous
toujours dans votre sac dans votre
voiture ou au travail
un patch ou des formes orales de
nicotine qui sont votre réserve
si vous vous trouvez un cours vous
pouvez toujours faire appel à votre
réserve au fur et à mesure vous aurez de
moins en moins besoin de ce traitement
vous allez donc pouvoir faire une
diminution très très en douceur
n'oubliez pas si vous ressentez une
difficulté vous pouvez toujours
augmenter les doses ça n'a aucune
importance
et ça peut vous éviter une reprise du
tabac vous pouvez maintenant poursuivre
votre sevrage tabagique pendant les mois
qui viennent de la même manière vous
avez en effet très bien géré les choses
il vous suffit de continuer
tranquillement à ce rythme là tous les
mois vous allez vous reposer la question
par rapport au traitement si c'est le
moment ou pas encore de diminuer la dose
et puis vous diminuerez très
progressivement jusqu'à la plus petite
dose de traitement comment arrêter le
traitement est ce que c'est le bon
moment c'est à vous de savoir si c'est
actuellement le bon moment où si c'est
encore un petit peu juste
si vous sentez que l'arrêt du tabac se
déroule sans grande difficulté que le
traitement est une aide qui est de moins
en moins indispensable que vous pouvez
parfaitement vous en passer c'est le
moment d'arrêter le traitement comment
faire pour arrêter le traitement
vous n'allez pas arrêter le traitement
si vous n'êtes pas à la dose la plus
faible des substituts nicotiniques
si vous êtes à la dose la plus faible
vous pouvez commencer à vous débarrasser
de ce traitement
comment faire vous allez commencer à
mettre le traitement un jour sur deux
les jours vous avez le patch et les
jours vous ne l'avez pas doivent être
identiques
si vous ressentez une
grande envie de fumer les jours vous
n'avez pas le patch c'est que c'est
encore un peu juste et le patch a encore
une utilité si vous ressentez la même
chose les jours avec et sans patch vous
êtes prêt à arrêter complètement un
traitement vous pourrez alors
tranquillement arrêter les patchs vous
pouvez aussi gardé quelques formes aura
de nicotine
si cela peut vous rassurer au fur et à
mesure vous en aurez de moins en moins
besoin
si vous prenez des formes orales de
nicotine vous pouvez tranquillement vous
en débarrasser progressivement et en
douceur
pour cela vous pouvez les alterner avec
des chewing gum ou des bonbons sans
sucre qui remplaceront ses gommes ou
s'est passé à la nicotine
vous pouvez aussi prendre des verres
d'eau qui souvent être bien à calmer une
envie de fumer ou une envie de sucre
vous pourrez ainsi diminuer
progressivement et en douceur ces
traitements
si vous sentez que vous avez une
dépendance aux formes orales de nicotine
cela n'a pas beaucoup d'importance car
il n'y a aucun danger
donc il faut être rassurés d'abord si
ensuite vous voulez vous en débarrasser
au bout de quelques mois de traitement
vous pouvez tranquillement reprendre des
patchs et refaire une diminution très
progressive de ces patchs en alternant
les gommes et les pastilles avec des
chewing-gums et des bonbons sans sucre
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de ce
programme
je suis ravi que vous ayez pu le suivre
jusqu'au bout que vous sentiez mieux que
vous ayez rajeuni parce qu'en fait quand
on arrête de fumer ont rajeuni un petit
peu c'est une bonne conclusion si vous
rencontrez des difficultés
vous pouvez toujours revenir vers ce
programme et nous aurons toujours des
solutions à vous proposer
il peut arriver qu'au bout d'un an ou
deux ans ou dix ans d'arrêt du tabac
vous traversiez une phase difficile dans
ces cas là je propose toujours la
reprise de substituts nicotiniques qui
aident à passer une période difficile
dans la vie qui peut arriver à n'importe
quel moment si vous traversez une
période difficile
il peut arriver que vous ayez de nouveau
envie de fumer il ne faut pas hésiter à
reprendre les traitements et à reprendre
quelques semaines voire quelques mois de
traitement avec une diminution
progressive
exactement comme vous l'avez fait
jusqu'à maintenant sachez surtout qu
autour de vous vous allez rencontrer des
gens qui vont vous encourager dans votre
sevrage qui seront comme vous qui auront
arrêté de fumer depuis quelques temps
voir depuis longtemps mais vous pouvez
aussi rencontré des gens qui au
contraire vous disent que après 10 ans
d'arrêt du tabac ils ont toujours envie
de fumer sachez que ces moments n'ont
rien à voir avec le manque physique
ressenti au début il s'agit simplement
de souvenirs de flash qui dure quelques
secondes et qui passent immédiatement
ils sont absolument gérable et vous
pourrez poursuivre votre sevrage
tabagique sans aucun problème même si au
bout de quelques années vous vous
souvenez de ces moments vous fumez vous
êtes maintenant un exemple pour tous les
fumeurs autour de vaud c'est à vous
maintenant de les accompagner de les
rassurer et de les encourager
un sevrage tabagique c'est à vous
maintenant de leur faire profiter de
votre expérience
alors n'hésitez pas
la respiration abdominale cette
respiration est un très bon outil pour
retrouver le calme la détente
vous pourrez la pratique et en plaçant
les demain pour me demain contre
l'abdomen en inspirant vous aller
gonfler un petit peu le ventre
poussé sur vos paumes de main et en
soufflant laisser le ventre se
rentraient se relâcher vous inspiré par
le nez en gonflant un petit peu le
ventre vous soufflez par la bouche en
laissant le ventre se relâcher vous
inspirez en gonflant un peu le ventre
puis en soufflant vous laisser le ventre
se relâcher vous pouvez laisser se
relâcher vos bras et continuer sur cette
respiration basse respiration
décontractante
aspiration de calme vous inspiré par le
nez en gonflant le ventre vous soufflez
par la bouche en laissant le ventre se
rentre
vous inspirez en gonflant le ventre et
vous soufflez par la bouche en laissant
le ventre se relâcher faites attention
de ne pas contracter vos épaules
conserver les bras bien décontracté en
continuant respirer en gonflant un petit
peu le ventre puis sur l'expiration en
laissant le ventre se détendre
[Musique]
les yeux fermés imaginer devant vous une
cible votre paquet de cigarettes
votre envie de fumer fixé cette image
cette idée est concentré toute votre
attention dessus vous allez souffler
puis en inspirant placer votre bras
fléchi points à la hauteur de les poules
rodney l'air en contractant puis en
soufflant projeter votre bras poings
fermés contre votre cible virtuel pour
l'anéantir laisser redescendre votre
bras doucement encore une fois vous
allez souffler puis en inspirant placer
votre bras poing fermé à la hauteur de
l'épaule contractée un instant et en
soufflant projeter votre bras poings
fermés sur votre cible une dernière fois
vous allez souffler puis en inspirant
placer votre bras point la hauteur de
l'épaule contractée un instant et en
soufflant projeter votre bras sur votre
cible virtuel pour l'anéantir
complètement
maintenant vous allez changer de bras
vous allez souffler puis en inspirant
place et l'autre main à la hauteur de
l'épaule contractée un instant et en
soufflant projeter votre bras sur votre
cible virtuel laisser redescendre
doucement votre bras encore une fois
vous allez souffler en inspirant
replacer votre poids en près de l'épaule
contractée un instant et en soufflant
projeter votre bras poings fermés sur
votre cible virtuel laisser redescendre
votre marc une dernière fois vous allez
souffler puis en inspirant ramener la
main poing fermé à la hauteur de
l'épaule contractée l'instant garder
l'air puis souffler et projeter votre
bras sur votre cible vous allez souffler
puis en inspirant replacer les demain
près des épaules puis en soufflant
projeter les deux points sur votre cible
et relâché encore une fois vous allez
souffler puis en inspirant placé les
deux mains et des épaules poings fermés
projeter les deux bras sur la cible en
soufflant et relâche une dernière fois
vous allez souffler puis inspirez placé
les deux mains près des épaules poings
fermés et en soufflant vous allez
projeter les deux bras sur votre cible
pour l'anéantir complètement laisser
redescendre vos bras tout seul
asseyez vous confortablement sur une
chaise vous pouvez fermer les yeux
prendre le temps de ressentir les points
d'appui de votre corps sur la chaise
le contact de vos pieds sur le sol
le contact de votre dos contre le
dossier la chaise de votre bassin sur la
chaise
vous pouvez laisser se détendre tout
votre corps dans cette agréable position
de détente
l'essai se diffuser cette détente depuis
le sommet de votre tête jusqu'à la
pointe de vos orteils tout votre corps
est maintenant complètement relaxe
vous pouvez commencer par souffler puis
en inspirant placez vos demain dans la
nuque soulever un petit peu les jambes
puis maintenez garder l'air et
contracter tout votre corps en fixant
dans cette tension musculaire votre
addiction votre dépendance vos mauvaises
habitudes
puis lorsque vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez souffler laisser filer l'air
entre les lèvres et éloigner ainsi de
vous cette dépendance vous libérer de
vos envies et de toute servitude
vous pouvez reprendre vous pouvez
commencer par souffler
puis en inspirant placez vos deux mains
derrière la tête soulevé vos jambes
garder l'air est contracté un petit peu
tout votre corps en fixant dans cette
tension musculaire vos habitudes
votre dépendance vos envies puis lorsque
vous le souhaitez vous pouvez souffler
laisser filer l'air éloigner ainsi de
vous la dépendance les habitudes les
envie de s'y arrête
vous pouvez reprendre une dernière fois
cet exercice vous commencez par souffler
puis en inspirant replacer vos deux
mains derrière la tête soulevé vos
jambes du sol puis garder l'air
contracté un petit peu tout le corps est
fixé encore une fois dans cette tension
musculaire votre addiction vos habitudes
de votre dépendance puis lorsque vous le
souhaitez vous allez souffler et
éloigner ainsi de vous la dépendance les
envies les habitudes
vous pouvez reprendre plusieurs fois cet
exercice et autant de fois que vous en
ressentirez le besoin
cet exercice de relaxation vous
permettra de gérer le stress lié à votre
sevrage tabagique
vous allez choisir un mot qui évoque
pour vous le calme le bien-être la
détente et sur chaque expiration
vous pourrez prononcé mentalement ce mot
de calme
vous allez inspirer et en soufflant
prononcé mentalement votre mot de calme
de bien être vous inspirer et en
soufflant prononcé mentalement ce mot de
détente de bien-être vous pouvez
continuer en inspirant puis en soufflant
prononcé pour vous ce mot de calme de
détente
vous a inspiré et sur chaque expiration
prononcé mentalement votre mot de calme
de bien-être
vous pouvez continuer en inspirant et en
soufflant prononcé mental
le mot de calme de détente de bien-être
vous inspirez et en soufflant vous
prononcez mentalement votre le mot qui
évoque le calme le bien-être vous pouvez
reprendre autant de fois que vous le
souhaitez cet exercice à tout moment
toute occasion
dès que vous sentez le stress lié à
votre sevrage devenir trop important
trop présent
utiliser le dossier de votre chaise
comme une barre posez vos avant bras
l'un sur l'autre le front sur les mains
allongé une jambe
derrière vous fléchissez la jambe
d'appui à l'avant
vous allez contracté le muscle fessier
pour soulever la jambe puis l'a laissée
aux descendre au sol vous pouvez
effectuer une dizaine de mouvements de
ce côté puis changez de jambe et
reprendre une dizaine de mouvements avec
l'autre champ pensez à bien gainer votre
ventre et à tenir votre dos bien droit
au fur et à mesure de vos entraînements
vous pourrez augmenter le nombre de
répétitions de mouvement
cet exercice est parfait pour la
tonification de vos muscles fessiers
placez vos mains on appuie sur les côtés
de la chaise souffler en soulevant vos
jambes et en ramenant les jeunes ouvert
la poitrine inspiré en reposant vos
jambes au sol vous pouvez faire une
dizaine de mouvements puis ensuite avec
l'entraînement augmenter le nombre de
répétitions
faites attention à conserver le dos bien
droit et le ventre bien guînes cet
exercice vous permettra d'éviter la
prise de poids liée au sevrage
le dos est bien à plat vos genoux sont
fléchi vos pieds posés au sol en
position parallèle et écartés de la
largeur de vos hanches vos fesses sont
serrés et votre ventre gay ni placer les
mains sous la nuque puis souffler en
contractant les abdominaux et en
soulevant le buste inspiré en revenant
au sol vous pouvez reprendre cet
exercice une dizaine de fois puis quand
vous serez mieux entraîné une quinzaine
puis une vingtaine de fois vous pouvez
varier en croisant votre coude vers le
jeu nous opposer vous soufflez vous
croisez coudes et genoux d'un côté vous
inspirez vous revenez au seul vous
soufflez vous croisez de l'autre côté
l'autre genou l'autre coude vous
inspirez vous revenez au sol vous
pourrez reprendre une dizaine de fois
cet exercice puis augmenter le nombre de
séries quand vous serez mieux entraînés
pour cet exercice plus tonique monter
les deux bras au dessus de votre tête
puis redescendez les en montant
alternativement le genou droit le genou
gauche
vous pouvez enchaîner plusieurs
mouvements plusieurs enchaînements une
minute deux minutes plus longtemps quand
vous serez un petit peu plus entraînés
cet exercice est très utile pour évacuer
le surplus d'énergie ou le stress généré
par le sevrage
vous pourrez le pratiques et facilement
à l'intérieur et à chaque fois vous en
ressentirez le besoin